(clairon)
- Avril 2008.
Vladimir Poutine arrive
pour assister au premier
etetetetet OTAN-Russie, en prin,
le sommet de la détente.
Mais c'est làa a a a a a a a a r
pour le président russe.
Car l'OTAN vient d'annoncer
qu'après la Croatie
la Géorgie deviendront membres,
mais pas tout de suite.
C'en est trop pour Vladimir
Poutine. Il est de mauvaise
humeur, mais il se retient,
alors que George W. Bush,
Pourtant, le président russeluis
devez comprendre que l'Ukraine
n'est
- "L'apparition d'un blo nos frs
sera considérée, en Russie,
comme une menace directe
contre notre sécurité."
- Ce qidididididident
ukrainien conteste.
"L'Ukraine n'est pas un  f f f t
un état indépendant, souverain."
Un mois plus tard, Vladimir
à Dimitri Medvedev, mais
il devient son premier ministre.
Ça ne change rien au plan de
Débu l l l l l l'armée russe
envahit la Géorgie et occupe
l'Ossétie du Sud puis          s
prorusses. Le conflit sera rude,
mais bref. Moscou reconnaît
les deux régions géorgiennes
le 26 août 2008 et en interditl.
Pour l'Ukraine ce sera
une autre paire de manches, car
le prorusse Viktor Ianoukovitch
renverse la décision ukrainiennn
européenne et à l'OTAN.
Les Ukrainiens nationalistes
se révoltent et ce sera le drame
La répression fera plus
rtrtrtrtrtrtrts.
Ianoukovitch s'enfuit en Russie.
Il........s s s s s s s s s s se
nationalistes et les éléments
prorusses d'Ukraine
s'accroissent et la révolte
et la Crimée.
La Crimée est surtout peuplée
par des Russes qui, sur la férél
largement remporté, réclament
l'adhésion à la Russie.
L'occupation se fera par
des soldats sans aucune marque
, , , , , , , , et l'annexion
suivra, sans aucun combat,
ratifiée par le pr 3 3 3 3 3 3 .
(rafales de tirs)
Dans le Donbass,
les séparatistes prorusses et
jusqu'à maintenant faisantenenet
réagit par des sanctions.
Des sanctions qui, on le voit
aujourd'hui, auront été
occidental affaibli par
alalalalalalalalald Trump
en admiration devant
Vladimir Poutine f f f f f f f r
Poutine a été sous-estimé.
On a sous-estimé son sens
de l'histoire et la rancune
de l'Empire soviétiqueururururu,
son désir de vengeance
égal
On a rapporté qu'Angela Merkel,
qui le connaissait bien,
a dit de lui qu'il avait
perdu contact avec la réalité
Récemment, l'entouraged'Emmanuet
comme rigide et paranoïaque,
Il ne serait plus le même que
celui qu'il a
On a supposé que cet homme
calculateur se contenteraitmpmp,
le Donbass et la Crimée,
comme pour la Géorgie en 2008.
On ne croyait pas
un si énorme coup de poker.